opening the doors i think there she is  oh  she was in africa in the morning  6th of february  in 1952  when she became queen  70 years on we prepare now for the  national anthem  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  well what a wonderful surprise joanna oh  my god  fantastic  fantastic  what a surprise alistair  wonderful for the queen i know sheila  wants to have been here but you know  she's undergoing some agonizing tedious  problems with her  feet and her  capacity to walk around and it has been  a worry but she's here  70 years sovereign of the united kingdom  14 other nations and the commonwealth  head of the commonwealth  brianna  i think just the most wonderful  ending to what has been  an absolutely spectacular  four days of platinum jubilee  celebrations  for the queen of course wanting to come  out onto the balcony